you know I would agree that
Consciousness is something that's
experienced something phenomenal so for
example my uh the taste of coffee the
smell of a rose uh the feeling of a
headache these are all specific
conscious experiences and so that's what
I'm what I mean when I talk about
conscious experiences and what's
remarkable is that
my my brilliant friends and colleagues
who are are studying this problem using
cognitive neuroscience and or physical
systems like artificial intelligences
uh theories like the integrated
information Theory or orchestrated
collapse of quantum States and
micropubules and so forth what's
remarkable is that um when you look at
all these theories there is not a single
specific conscious experience
that has ever been explained what is the
pattern of integrated information that
must be the taste of vanilla and could
not possibly be the smell of a rose what
is the orchestrated collapse the precise
orchestrated collapse of quantum States
and microtubules that must be the taste
of chocolate and could not be uh you
know the taste of garlic
if you ask and I these are my friends so
I've asked them in public that
conferences and so forth give me a
specific conscious experience that you
that your theory can tell us because
these are supposed to be theories of
conscious experience so they should
explain conscious experiences so what
experience can you explain what
integrated information must be the taste
of chocolate or or whatever one you you
can do and what's remarkable is there is
no physical Theory
or integrated information Theory or work
straight clubs whatever there is no
theory of that type that can explain
even one specific conscious experience
we're batting zero nothing there's
nothing on the table so so that's why I
said it's premature to talk about so how
could computers boot up Consciousness we
we have no idea about how anything could
boot up Consciousness right now from a
physical system literally nothing is on
the table so so until we can solve that
we don't know how neurons could possibly
boot up Consciousness there's nothing on
the table so that's why this is a you
know I said it was premature to be
asking whether
um you know only biological systems can
boot up Consciousness not AIS we have no
theory about how biological systems can
boot up conscience there's there's
literally nothing on the table that
makes sense and I predict that there
that's a principled problem this is not
simply these are bright people these are
good friends of mine they're they're
brilliant but when you start with space
and time and physical objects inside
space and time like particles or neurons
or whatever
um you're starting with what physics
tells us is not fundamental reality so
if you're starting with something that
we know is not fundamental good luck
trying to boot up a theory of anything
else from that so so that's my sort of
my diagnosis of the problem so we have
to go after
I think I I agree with with Bernardo you
know starting with an idea in which
Consciousness itself is fundamental and
Bernard was going after that
philosophically as a scientist I'm
trying to go after it mathematically try
to get a mathematically precise theory
of the very kinds of things that that
Bernard was talking about and then show
how space and time
are booted up precisely from a theory of
Consciousness so get a dynamics of
Consciousness outside of space-time and
boot up space and time and and for
example
um scattering amplitudes of particles
get all of that without a hand wave get
all of that derived precisely from a
theory of Consciousness so in other
words we've tried to start with space
and time and particles and biology and
try to boot up a theory of Consciousness
from that we've not gotten a single
success not one specific conscious
experience but if we start with
Consciousness being fundamental and the
mathematical model of that then I think
we can boot up space and time and
particles and show where they come up
and when we can back 100 on that so I
think we should start with Consciousness
and show space and time is just a user
interface that some Consciousness is
used but if we start the other direction
our best science tells us good luck
you've got the wrong Foundation